attract a diverse workforce and increase
employment opportunities the goal of the
u.s department of labor
and its new investment in apprenticeship
programs
15 states are receiving more than 130
million in grants to expand career
opportunities
and job training programs for all
workers right now governor sissel act
says one of the focuses is to educate
the youth on how much certain jobs
they're paying
when you learn the value of being a
carpenter an electrician or a chef
or whatever it might be you're taught
from good jobs i mean these are careers
these are minimum wage jobs and some
will say geez i don't want to be a
plumber i mean i don't want to make nine
bucks an hour
and i'm like are you kidding me you have
no idea what floors you're making
so uh i think we need to do a better job
getting the word out of how great these
jobs can be our state received nearly
four million dollars in grants
sysalack is scheduled to meet tomorrow
with members of the nevada cove at 19
private sector task force to provide
some updates on their work and
accomplishments throughout this pandemic